welcome to the Python epiphanies
tutorial I named this tutorial
epiphanies because I am hoping and based
on experience teaching this a few times
I've got some evidence that at least
some of you will have some aha moments
during it where you go oh that's how
pythons really doing it
I've taught Python in various various
audiences for quite a few years
University kids
scamp's grade 6 grade 10 to 12 industry
and one of the things I noticed is the
intermediate Python introduction of
Python there's lots of good tutorials
and books etc advanced there's some good
stuff intermediate it kind of felt like
there were things that I was noticing
and I wasn't seeing other people
focusing on how to get past sort of a
plateau that some people have when
they're moving trying to move from inter
from beginner towards advanced and
they're in that in-between phase the zip
file at the bitly hi Daddy NYC -
epiphanies has in it a knife - notebook
a really big one that might crash your
browser has a bunch of smaller ones one
per section and it has an HTML file if
you're going to for the exercises I
actually encourage you to use the HTML
file and type them in yourself I think
you will learn better and you can do
that in an eye - notebook oh sorry
Jupiter notebook or ipython or just a
regular Python the read eval print loop
the repple which is just the prompt
where you type Python and starts asking
you questions or you can start typing in
expressions I will be doing mostly
one-liners I'll be using Python 3 for
you can use an earlier version including
- whatever and it'll be almost all the
same I'll point out a couple minor
places where you might get tripped up I
have put errors in the code including
exercises on purpose and I've thought
about which ones to put in and why it's
to try to teach you something I this is
this is not data specific I'm not going
to talk much about pandas or numpy or
not at all it's it's its core Python the
thing I so in terms of myself I've been
working in the industry for 25 years
using Python for about 50 1012 I
currently am working as a software
developer Software Architect with a
quant group in Toronto they're using
Python lot and I'm trying to help them
use it well I asked a question earlier
before we started so some of you weren't
here yet but I was trying to get a sense
for where you're all coming from and a
fair number of people a few people had
Python as their first language I would
say at least half the room has been
using Python less than 2 years unless
all the people arrive late
somehow throw that off and the quite a
few people came from other languages
where the the way that people the way
you may have been trained to think about
variables is different than the way
python works and you might not have
figured that out yet and that's one of
the things I'm going to focus on quite a
bit is names and objects so much so that
the first 10 minutes you might think
this is way too slow
bear with me if you want to leave wait
15 minutes and in these and it's but and
then I use that as the theme going
throughout sort of talking about names
and namespace changes any questions
before I get started ok well one of the
thing I wanted to mention this I also
have a version of this o'reilly video
that i did a couple months ago it's a
longer version of this so this one's 90
minutes sorry this one's 90 minutes
that's a full two and half hours and
what I've done is taken just the best
parts of that content to deliver to you
so hopefully that works ok so let's
start by just talking about objects very
basically and I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
really slowly to make sure you
understand what's going on right so in
this second
I mean just some here can you still see
that and you're in the back have any
problem seeing that text okay that's
more reasonable all right so really
slowly what happens when I type one at
the interactive prompt in Python Python
sees some syntax parses it figures out
ah that's an integer literal I can I
know how to create an object based on
what the user is typing in it goes off
and it creates the integer object which
represents an integer the instant or one
and that interrupts is not just the
bytes that have the 1 in it it's a bunch
of other stuff about the instance of the
integer class it's got a reference to
the class but other things as well and
you'll see that later when we look at
sizes if you look at the size of the
object one that gets created it's quite
a few bytes I think it's 24 or something
like that okay and then when I hit enter
here because the expression that I asked
Python to evaluate has a value which
isn't none it prints the value of that
expression back on the standard output
so that's actually what's happening in
the Revue eval print loop so I can
create objects via literals and none of
these should be surprises I'm just
creating you know there's a float and
the complex there's a string literal a
bytes literal all right there's a tuple
a list a dictionary is set all right
another way you can access objects in
Python is they're pre created for you
false and true are an example alright so
if you look at false and true or look at
none which is interesting is it stuck is
it not answering I thought I evaluated
line 11 all right if it returns the
value which is none it's not going to
print it right I told you that in the
repple the expression is only going to
be printed out if it has a value that's
other than none right so the false and
true are names that refer to pre created
objects that represent false and true
none is a name that points to or
references a pre created object there is
one object in Python which is the none
object and I can't see in a sense I
again I can't but when I hit enter on
didn't show me anything because its
value is none so that's kind of a weird
case I mean just a couple others that
are not implemented ellipses etc there
are a bunch of built-in types and
functions here examples of two built-in
types int and list and two examples of
built-in functions function any and
function Len
so everything in Python at runtime is an
object everything in Python is an object
it has a single value a single type it
has some number of attributes it has one
or more base classes might be more
because Python has multiple inheritance
it has a single unique ID and it has one
or more names or occasionally 0 and
those names are in various namespaces
and I want to explore these briefly and
again for those of you who just arrived
and for those of you who are starting to
get bored trust me the first 10 minutes
it's going slow I'm trying to I'm trying
to articulate this in a very consistent
way that makes that will help you think
about Python the way I think you should
think about the way pythons working to
help you go faster in Python and
understand what's going on so every
object has a has a type right and we can
look at the type of int and again let me
slow down again here what happened here
is Python saw the one created an object
to represent the integer one took a
reference that object sent it off to
whatever the name type refers to which
happens to be a function that function
call that function took that reference
did whatever magic it did and it created
or returns a new object which is an
object that looks like int when it gets
printed out so it returned the type
which is the int type is int an object
or a type both it's a type but
everything is an object in Python so
it's definitely not a it's a it's the
type of type one try it out but it meant
a type float complex type STR type bytes
again you'll see stuff this is some of
those so the bytes one you'll see is
Python Python two it works as well
there's a list a dictionary a set so I'm
just going through the same
sets of stuff I did earlier Oh the type
of nun
this one doesn't show up as nothing it's
not blank it actually did show me a
value in this case the type of nun is
the nun type all right so this is a
singleton type the nun type which has
one instance which is know which is one
which is none
actually I don't quote me on that I'm
not sure how its implemented
probably is implemented in C I don't
know every object has some number of
attributes so true is a name in the
current namespace which refers to an
object if I use dot and then some valid
Python identifier after it I'm asking
Python go get the attribute in that
namespace it's an object kind of has a
namespace which is its attributes and
return that value to me
and I get this string right by the way
the way you pronounce this if you
haven't heard it's true dot dunder doc
double underscore doc double underscore
is pronounced dunder dunder doc so true
is dunder doc attribute is just a string
which is pretty similar to the help that
it it's the doc string and it's the help
that you know if you type help true
you'll you'll get back some of that
you'll get back all of that and some
more
here's an object so here what's going on
again slowing down to brainwash you a
little bit here the object string
literal creates a string object that
string object I'm asking it does it have
a please go try to fetch the named under
add from it which is give me a method
and it gets back a method wrapper add of
string object at and gives some memory
address right is that callable one I'm
gonna call the callable function alright
so again slowing down string object gets
created I act I asked can we get the add
attribute from it that object is
returned it's passed off to whatever
function call bo refers to that function
returns an object which when printed
shows up as true that's all the layer
that's going underneath I'm not saying
you should think about this all the time
usually you want to think at a high
level of abstraction but I think it'll
help you so yes add is callable and we
can call it that way if I just want to
do addition on a string
you can see the exclamation point now
shows up on there every object has one
more base classes you can actually get
at these through attributes and we'll
look at these a little bit later as well
but if you look at throughs dündar class
attribute its bool and if you look at
the dunder class attributes and under
basis attribute Basie's is the plural of
base because it might be more than one
it returns me a tuple of all the base
classes well there's only one most
objects in Python most most classes in
Python only have one super type and this
is this one's true as well
interesting that true which is a boolean
is implemented as a subtype of it's
alright so bool is a subtype of in
superclass of bool is yet one of the
things that I find interesting Laura
Creighton had a post a long time ago it
when Google was added to Python arguing
against it saying this is not a good
idea it makes it harder to teach case
you're curious can go search that I can
look at let me just pull out the zeroth
element of that tuple and look at its
base classes and I get object right so
true is a subclass is an instance of
bool subclass event subclass of object
yes
so what I'm doing sorry we're line 32 oh
is instance let me let me think about
that or answer later we'll keep moving
good that's interesting question a good
catch so when I say subclass I would
mean a direct subclass I think it'll
become more clear so the method
resolution order for classes is stored
in the dunder mro attribute so I can
look at Bull's
mro and it will give me a weird error oh
no it doesn't give me the right I got
confused there so there we go I think
that might answer your question right
the right way to do all of this if you
need to is with the inspect module and
this will give us an error because why
okay well there's the I just happen to
got the I got the doc string for that
simple function right in my error
message and I can see it returns the
tuple of base classes so I'm supposed to
pass it
I passed it in instance all right so
let's pass it the class or the type of
true and they ever get that's the right
way to do it all right it's object
string object Python three you'll save a
string in there somewhere okay almost
done the slow stuff and we'll start
doing more interesting things where I'll
reinforce the language of names etc so
ID of three in Python the ID is ideas of
function that will return a unique
identifier for an object in C Python
currently it happens to return memory
address and that's useful in a few edge
cases when you're doing stuff with
external extensions typically you should
not rely on that it's not true in every
implementation of Python or guaranteed
to be but you can you know check the in
so you can check the IDs of all these
things so the other way we create
objects is to call functions or classes
or dunder call methods all right so we
we call other callable objects functions
are the primary example of callable
objects but there are other ones we'll
see so let's look at an example that
there's len is a name which refers to
this object which is a built-in function
and i can say is it callable yes i can
call it on a string and I get 16 as the
length of that string there is a dunder
Len attribute of every string types
instance every object of type string and
you can call that directly if you want
that's what Len actually does it looks
to see if it has one calls it int is
callable right remember int I did a type
of one that got back in so int as that
built a name is a type but you can call
it just like you can call classes and if
you call it it does things and you can
explore the various things it does if
you call it with no arguments you know
returns are the base value or the
default value or it's probably better
worked for that same predict if you call
it it returns an empty dictionary you
can actually call it like a function and
pass it parameters
probably seeing this if you haven't it's
it's handy slightly better syntax in
some situations limitation of course is
the names have to be valid Python
identifiers and of course the order you
get back why is it different well
because dictionaries don't have order
they're implemented to be fast for key
lookup not to be ordered if you need an
order dictionary you can use collections
order dict type true is not callable and
if i try it'll tell me it's not callable
but bool the type itself is callable
right okay some information about
exercises I want to give you a chance
now for just about three minutes just go
try these exercises and just explore and
think about what you've just learned so
we'll start to get in about three or
four minutes know that that's an
attribute so that's
hmmm I can't turn off it's an attribute
of the object that attribute happens to
be a callable which you can call it it's
a method ice
those of you who don't have the aren't
trying this yourself look at that and
predict what it's gonna do those of you
who are trying yourself do the same
thing before you don't just type in hit
it or look at it say okay what's this
going to do think about what it's doing
and then see if you get it right
okay I'm gonna hurry us along now I know
that I expect none of you finished that
set and that's okay
partly it was just a stretch break for
your brain stop listening to me
but I encourage you to try these later
and again if you want to try there are a
couple exercise sections for sections I
am demoing that you can get excuse me
from the Orion video link to the full
set feel free to go through that on your
own so let's just try these see if
there's anything new to learn usually
there are when I have you do exercises
what does derd do there is a built-in
function that if you pass it an object I
if you pass it something because it's
got to be an object of its Python it'll
show you all the names of the attributes
that are available on that instance so
lots of stuff there's the five point
zero dot add five point zero as a float
and there's the add method wrapper we'll
see that later again and it's of the
float object that got created or found
when we type when that 5.0 was evaluated
remember it went off create the fluid
object is that method wrapper callable
yep so let's call it this is gonna fail
or succeed yeah we're not adding to
anything right how does it fail expected
one argument got zero alright so we'll
pass it one argument we get nine what's
going on here for dot add can't find it
why well because it sees the four dots
oh here comes a floating-point number
and then it's not a floating-point
number so there are some things in
Python they're couplers three or four
little weird edge cases in syntax which
are interesting in theory I think they
probably could correct them and it would
just slow down the interpreter so if you
put parentheses around it well then I
can say that interrupts the syntax
confusion for Python and again I get the
method wrapper I can hit add here's a if
you're curious how big things are you
can import this I've given a different
name here just to make save you typing
there's a string interesting 53 for a
string of 428 for an integer and then if
you're writing Python 2 you might see
some interesting boundary conditions
here in terms of what gets returned no
probably not
anyway those are some very large numbers
Python if you get past the maximum
integer size of your platform it will
magically start using long ants which
are slower but you can use them okay
it's the first foundational piece make
sure we're all on the same page second
one I'm gonna talk about names yes I
haven't explored that how different a
little bit okay and now you're in 32-bit
or 64-bit 64 so yeah I'm not sure so
names you got to understand names in
Python so and I'm gonna show you a bunch
of stuff about them and again I got
slowdowns this is gonna go I'm gonna go
really slowly and articulate very
carefully and you'll notice I almost
never use the word variable because most
people when they think variable they
don't think about something that can
vary or math variable they think of the
variable I learned in the other language
or that I'm used to from just the
general understanding of variable in
programming which isn't quite consistent
with what Python is doing for a lot of
people so every object has as I said
earlier zero maybe but usually one or
more names in one or more namespaces so
names are just references to objects and
they work just like dictionaries
namespaces work just like dictionaries
and we'll see that so if I type if I
enter if I call the function dirt with
no arguments it says show me all the
attributes of the current namespace or
all the names that are available in the
current namespace and you will get a lot
in ipython if you're running the
notebook and so we're just going to skip
back there and I'm instead going to
create that file and
load it back in and execute it and then
I can just say okay show me what the
names are okay there's nothing so now
I've got nothing because I basically
remember all the ones I had and I'm
saying ignore those but this is a lot
closer to what you'd see if you just did
the repple you would see almost no names
in your current namespace so nothing
here so if I type a Python sees a Python
identifier and says ah that must be a
name look at let me go look in this
thing that's very much like a dictionary
the name space and see if that key has a
value in it if so I'll return the value
that's how they do it in this case we
get a name error because there is no key
in that dictionary or that dictionary
like thing okay so what this does a
equals 300 this is a name space
operation this is a change to the name
space you might hear people say this is
creating a variable it's not creating a
variable in a high-level sense it is but
it's not creating a variable in usual
sense remember from what I when I was
talking so laborious least slowly
earlier the number 300 Python sees that
goes off and creates an integer object
representing the end 300 all the a
equals does is says oh I want to
remember that thing right it's like I
wrote on a post-it a and I stuck it on
that object that's one way to think
about it the other is to think that
we've got this dictionary this is oh
there's that object out there let's add
a as a key in the dictionary and the
value is going to be a reference to that
integer object that got created as part
of that expression okay so if you think
about Python if you think about
variables as boxes where you put values
that can be a little bit misleading and
get you in trouble
part of why that can be the Bemis part
part away so the reason that way of
thinking exists in our industry is
because that's the way compiled language
is all of them used to have to work that
way and the reason they had to work that
way that's why types were that way right
Python the type is carried in the object
the 300 it's not carried in the name and
it happens at runtime not a compile time
in other statically compiled languages
the type has to be known at compile time
because the compiler has to know how
much memory to allocate and if you say
300 plus if I say
a plus-one it has to know what machine
instructure's the issue to do the
addition because a float add and an int
add and a string concatenation are
different machine instructions Python
that's all done at runtime okay so let's
change the namespace look at that
there's my namespace it changed it now
has a name a referring to the object 300
now here I don't see the reference
actually see the value because it's
dereferencing it for me so now when I
access a Python looks up in the current
namespace for the key a the name a and
if it finds it it returns whatever a
refers to amazing just let that sink in
what that's doing that's very handy
because then I don't have to put you
know quotes and curly braces everything
around it so it's just like a dictionary
where I can get some free syntax so
here's roughly what I've already
described so I won't repeat it now a is
a name in the dictionary which write was
in the namespace which refers to 300 if
I say a equals 400 that's a reassignment
and all it's doing is the 400 gets
created out there somewhere and I'm
saying have a point to that 400 instead
of whatever it pointed to before right
so I'm not taking what used to hold 300
and clobber you with a 400 no three
hundreds out there in memory 400 got
stuck out there in memory and I'm just
saying to the namespace stop having a
refer to 300 have a root 34 refer to 400
instead okay namespace operations here
so now we can see a refers to 400 so
what's be equal a gonna do
yes question does this reenter get
garbage collected none of your business
mm-hmm all right and and I joked but the
point is it really isn't if you have to
worry about that sure worry about that
but typically when the the reference
count on an object tracks how many
references there are how many names
there are indirect or direct in all
sorts of different namespaces to an
object when that goes to zero Python has
right to go clean it up and it usually
will do it right away and I'm saying
usually because I'm talking Python
generally not Python not see Python I
just a bigger version different
implementations can do it differently
okay alright so when I say B equals a
what I what I'm doing there as I'm
saying I did the he'll do it again
notice it didn't print anything here
because the expression B equals a is
actually not an expression it's a
statement doesn't have a value unlike C
so what I said is dereference a go look
up what a refers to and I want B to be a
new name in the current namespace that
refers to the same thing that a referred
to so now B and a are two names for the
name same object alright now if I access
a I get four hundred four hundred and if
I do the dirt n you can see sorry go
away you can see right up there it's
where the three hundred the four the
four hundred now this again this is what
misleading because you see two string
representations of it print it out
there's only one four hundred object out
there well actually I don't know if
that's true or not but well look at that
later you can look at their IDs oh no I
dunno because we didn't assignment it's
alright
their IDs are the same so they are the
same object and a is B so is is an
operator in Python that checks to see
that the two expressions in this case
names that get looked up are they the
same object it's not equality it's are
they the same object okay and that will
touch on later again it's important to
understand okay so del a anybody want to
take a stab at what del a does be brave
removes a from the namespace Dell is a
namespace operation right it's just
changing the dictionary its removing the
key get rid of that key value pair right
and again because I got rid of the name
the reference count on the object we
represent the inch or 400 decremented
did it go to 0 del is done a no because
b still refers to it right
if I now look for a it says name error
but B is still there so if I say B
equals walk again I'm gonna skip the
comments cuz I'm talking through them
instead B equals walk again in a
compiled language where I said B is an
int then to say B is not an int it's a
string is going to be a problem because
it throws off the whole compile chain
and the instructions being issued and
the type checker doesn't like it so that
it can do all those things when Python B
is just a name I could have a name refer
to some other object so there I did and
there's B and it's got an ID okay and
then if I know at this point has 400 be
garbage collected probably and if I try
oh did that twice sorry so if I tried lb
it removes it and then I evaluated the
same cell a second time all right and if
you look there's nothing there so I
mentioned that objects quoting from this
tutorial the python tutorial object
attributes are also like dictionaries
and in a sense the set of attributes of
an object also form a namespace so I
think that's a good way to think about
it
in Python 2 you can create a namespace a
simple empty object a class that does
nothing that way you can actually import
from the types module after Python 3 3
to do the same thing so let's create one
of these trivial objects I now have an
instance of a simple namespaces class
it's just basically just think of this
is an object or it's a record type or
something like that so if you're looking
at it's gonna give me some kind of
whatever tells me what his type is what
tells me it's a namespace so if I look
at its dictionary it's got nothing in it
if I set some of the attributes to
certain values ie if I add attribute
names to the namespace which that object
has or is and make them refer to the
objects that just got created then if I
look at the dunder dict attribute of the
object we can see that's exactly where
it stores them right and I can access
them same way all right so that's the
way namespaces work when you think about
attributes of an object so earlier I
said
made some vague comment about its and
did the 400 get cleaned up and are they
the same well they were in that case
because I said a equals 400 B equals the
same thing a is so they were referring
to the same object this is not
surprising or maybe this surprising I
don't know
so I equals J is not surprising that
should not be surprising 10 does equal
10 and for some of you because yeah is
it surprising or not some of you this
will be surprising you're not surprising
the behavior is different right so don't
use is unless you mean it
use equal if what you're looking for is
equality what's actually going on here
is that Python pre creates some integers
and others it doesn't and it does that
for efficiency reasons and you can
actually you can actually check right so
I is not J but still I equals J 500 does
equal 500 so in this case we can Intuit
that there are two 500 objects out there
in pythons memory right now in case
you're curious and it tells you why
there in case you're curious let's just
go look and I narrowed this down but you
can see that right around between minus
6 and minus 5 we start to get different
memory addresses and above 256 we get
different memory addresses so you can go
look at the C code to get us out to but
just from the Python level you can see
also Python pre creates integers in the
range minus 5 to plus 256 because
they're so commonly used it makes sense
to do them up front is this gonna help
you in your coding no not at all it's
kind of alright a few minutes to do some
exercises with dirt again if you're
doing it in that you only need this def
dunder der if you or underscore der I
mean if you're doing it in the ipython
notebook you don't want all the noise so
take two or three minutes take five
minutes and do some exercises there yes
the attributes that you showed that went
into the namespace dictionary Max's
thoughts does that mean any old
dictionary you can access you know so
are you saying does every object have
like let me get past that for the people
who want to just imagine what's gonna
happen
okay I'm gonna hurry us along again
because I'm I'm choosing for you that
you'd rather have more the only 90
minutes you don't need as many breaks
and you'll get more from it if I show
you more stuff so I'm gonna do a derp
remind you to oh yeah again if you're
running like Python oh geez yet so I'm
gonna create my little fake one here get
rid of the clutter equals one V has the
value 1 what's in my current name-space
just V got added you know to it it's
type int W equals V remember that's just
saying whatever V referred to make W a
new name if it does exist alright you or
change it if it does so that it also
refers to whatever V was right and of
course if you do that then B is w's
gonna be true here's a little list 1 2 3
so now and and M both refer to the same
list and you can see all those names are
in there VW n and M M isn't yep because
they refer to the same list so if I
change list M does list and get changed
well hopefully that's a nonsensical
question why would you ask if list why
would you call them list M and list end
they are the same list right therefore
if you change it it will change and you
can see that attribute there's a method
there
let's change addition to be subtraction
whew glad we can't do that let's import
get ref count from sis and give it a
short name so you can type it when
you're working on these later if you
want
wow I start up Python I start up by
Python notebook there are 16,000
references to the none object already
anyone is writing Python we're just bear
how many are there call it out if you
figure they don't just it'd be a lot
less than if you're running ipython
notebook or Jupiter notebook with
ipython in here how about the company
one zero three seven already a thousand
just running by
okay object the base class of all the
other classes and of which instances are
a sub our class our instances of those
already 2500 those if you call object
remember I said you call bool you get
false you call in you get 0 if you call
with an arguments if I call object with
no arguments I get a new object that it
just exists and it's unique and if you
ever need a sentinel value this is a
great way to get it right because now
this value there is no other value that
you can throw me in a file or over the
network or typed in that is going to be
the same as the sentinel value right
yeah if you're ever you think he
casually need this right it's like what
can I use minus one because it's all the
others are positive how do I know I get
to the end of this whatever I'm some
kind of way of stopping when I'm done
processing some things that's one way to
do it course there other ways to do it
with to stop processing like exceptions
but anyway I create this and then let's
say how many references are there to it
and there are two maybe what are the two
someone mention this this was mentioned
yesterday I think so one is the name
sentinel value in my current namespace
what's the other reference to sentinel
value to the to the object that I just
created anyone yeah nope because
underscore here refs again sentinel
value equals there's no that's not an
expression that has a value it's just an
assignment refs is gonna return the two
it's in the in the rest function itself
in the get ref count in get ref count
the there is a name defined as a
parameter in the signature and in the
content in the body of that function the
ref count function refers to whatever it
was passed in with the name that's the
second one right so it's a little bit of
a trick question because how many
references are there to that object
right now well there's only one but when
refs was running there were too soon as
ref returned there was only one
interesting three in the repple I'll
explore that later yeah
well ipython notebook it's yeah
interesting I wonder why that is I mean
I expect it's because I Python notebook
is saving some things and it maybe even
saving what it save interesting to track
those down okay so you can use object if
you need to and the only time this
expression will be true is if it's
actually the value that you owe
typos look at oh no that's true here as
well I was gonna say the only time it
would all right having a little angst
here that is that true for equality as
well as I think it is I think if you
take object equality it's it's it also
is always gonna be I never thought about
that
this ought to be this shot probably to
have been it is no no it is equal in a
sense of value would want to be equal
anyway it doesn't matter very much let's
look at a few others
refs so does it make sense to pre create
Python integer objects that are between
-5 and 256 looks like it probably is if
you want to know the whole list look at
that whole bunch of them it tapers off
near the end interesting to do this for
a lot bigger range of numbers and see is
there you can go make the case that we
should start pre creating more maybe
tipple assignment it's kind of nice in
Python you've seen me doing that a few
times or at least returning was right so
I can assign as long as the length of
the iterable notice I didn't say I said
something very generic general it could
be a list could be whatever is the same
as the number of names you're trying to
assign you can do that you can also do
the swap trick which you don't need the
temp in between because of that the way
that works and it worked just fine we
got two and the one so there's a tuple
there's another tuple without the
parentheses but it's still a tuple
there's a list there's a sequence that's
iterable right all of these work in
Python 3 you get some pretty cool
iterable unpacking which is nice alright
so I can say ijk and all the rest
and I get a list I can say you can put
the stars are in the middle right and
you get that you can even do it like
that only two items on the right so
that's very handy in some situations I
get it it's just very nice to have that
in Python 3 ok namespaces a little bit
more scopes in search order so anything
new here a scope is a section of python
code where a namespace is directly
accessible you can just type the name in
Python says oh you must be checking the
current namespace in the scope which
again that was not said very well you
you want to know what the current scope
which may include enclosing namespaces
friend directly accessible namespaces
use dot notation when we've seen the re
with objects direct namespace search
order internal scope contains local
names namespaces of enclosing functions
started with the nearest enclosing scope
mil scope contains the current modules
Global's outer Moscow is the namespace
containing built-in names have you
noticed that in all the dirt all the
calls to dirty you've never seen Len but
I used it you've never seen Kabul but
I've used it so that's where the
built-ins comes in you can go explore
that as well it's interesting so here's
the real story on namespaces all
namespaces changes all only space
changes happen in the local scope okay
so assignment reassignment del import is
a namespace operation it does more than
that but it's a namespace operation
right because what does it do you say
import space and then you give it a pot
a valid Python identifier and Python in
that case doesn't go look in the
namespace to find what that name are
first to because it won't be there but
it goes and finds a module somewhere
that has that name and makes it true
that it's in the namespace so if both
goes and imports it creates this
imported object and then it adds
something to the current namespace def
defining functions
create a new name class creates a new
name function parameters the name in the
signature creates a new name in the
scope of the function in a for loop you
can create a new name
alright exceptions with and docstrings
do it implicitly if anyone finds one I
still missed it's quite possible let me
know afterwards and I'll edit so you
should never reassigned built-in names
so let's do that
mmm all right there's the built-in
function so f1 so in here I'm going to
print out what value did we what's way
where is think about where when this
function gets evaluated and then
executed it's gonna get evaluated in
this cell executed down here what is
lending and refer to I suspect it's
gonna refer to the built in function
here but then alright after that I'm
gonna change the name space in the
function by adding a new name Len which
is going to be a reference to the code
object the function object that gets
compiled when this function gets read by
the Python by Python and then inside
that function I'm gonna add a new name
Len which is a range object and I'm
gonna print what it is because I'm
curious and then I'm gonna return it
print that one return again in the
details of of this I mean I want you to
think about this is ok you can do this
again not a good idea cuz your readers
gonna be confused because lens a
built-in but this is helps you think
about how namespaces work and how scopes
work inhale looking up names works so
we'll define that function and then
we'll call it never make last-minute
edits to your slides
I forgot that that oh no actually that
might not be the problem I added this
and didn't think y'all would it be nice
to show that as well
all right let's let's skip that for now
and come back to it and then here is a
slightly different example small change
alright so getting back to this assuming
sorry that didn't work we'll go fix it
later I want to fix it later because I
want to show you something else first so
Len is now the built-in function Len all
right let's overwrite it just directly
with an integer object 99 overwrite it
now
terrible language now let's make the
name Len refer to that integer object
instead of the built in function it used
to refer to all right so now if I
defined this function and I call it
what's it gonna do what errors are gonna
give think about that you have the
intuition it's not gonna work or maybe
you know it's not gonna work
but what errors are gonna give ya lenz
gonna say you can't call a string oh
sorry you can't call an INT right
because I said Len s equals that was
what s referred to is that string and
then I'm gonna call 99 and passing it
walk it doesn't make any sense right
that's the air we get all right and of
course Len hasn't changed and I can
delete it
oh I've just leave the Len function
right no I've just uncovered it right
because there's the built-in namespace
the global namespace when you add
something to one namespace it covers up
the other one but when you delete it it
only deletes it from the current
namespace because it's a namespace
operation and all names ASAP operations
happen in the local namespace and so
then the built-in one is visible again
okay and then print lens gonna work for
us
thank you pass let's try that with pass
well can't do it with pass
both namespaces not easily you could but
it'd be awkward right like you should
not overwrite so built-in names are
loaded at runtime and you can mask those
names or hide those names by adding a
local name local to your whatever your
namespace is which might be inside a
function nested in a function etc yes so
you can you can add names which Shadow
the built in names you can't do things
some things you can't do though right
like pass it's invalid syntax so some of
these things are keywords and you can't
override them or hide them others are
just built-in names yeah not easily not
easily there's a built-ins module you
can go explore and that I assume would
still have a reference to it qualified
on what on built-ins yeah you could
probably do that don't do it yeah I
don't know there's some power that comes
with allowing you to override things
mash them dangerous but yeah that's an
interesting question there are plenty of
people around here the holes who could
answer that ask Bret you might know okay
so let's look at some surprising
behavior related to function locals X
I'm gonna make a new name in the local
name space of the repple which is gonna
refer to the integer object representing
the integer 1 unit tired me saying all
those words it's hard isn't it alright
and then I'm gonna call it and it's
gonna print in test outer scoping the
name up function X is equal to 1 cool
how about let's create a local here so x
equals 2
why isn't next to here oh because I
haven't called that function we'll need
to find it right so X is one from up
here I've defined a function test local
where I'm going to assign a local X
equal to this namespace operation is
gonna happen in the local scope of the
function all right so now when I call
test local I should see X equal to Q
it's working and X will still be 2 or
we'll be back to 1 back to 1 all right
how about this one looks pretty similar
to the other one I'm gonna print what X
is what should give me the X equal 1
then I'm gonna set equal to 3 I could
print it again I suppose let's just
double check X test unbound local so
anyone run into that error and go what's
going on you probably figured out those
of you who run into it you figured out
by now hopefully or maybe not those of
you haven't what's going on here is that
namespace operations so here's a
namespace operation X equal 3 that
happens in the test unbound local
function and when python compiles the
code it says oh they've assigned X in
this function therefore X is a local and
then when it executes the function it
says all they want to access X and X is
a local and so it tries to access X
which is a local but it hasn't yet been
set up
right so unbound local it's the lowest
look closest thing you get to an
uninitialized variable in Python if you
are you familiar with that term
let's week actually go look at this it's
kind of cool
let's go see behind the scenes all right
so test unbound local is a name which
refers to the function object let's go
look at that object let's look at its
code all right and we can see some
things about its code there's its
argument count there are no arguments
passed the signature has no arguments no
parameters the name of the function is
test unbound local nut you notice that
this name shows up place by the way
test unbound local right here deaf test
bun Ellen unbound local creates a
function object which has an attribute
the string test unbound local it also
inserts the same string test Elmo test
unbound local into the current namespace
so that name sore goes to places when we
did the death anyway so there's its name
and we can look at the names used in
there there's a print that gets used in
there and here are a number of locals
and the names of the locals right so by
the time this code has been compiled
Python knows that there's a local name X
so when it tries to access it and well
let's really see what's going on all
right when it tries to access it here's
the byte code that python constructs all
right
so store fast is the assignment of sorry
is this I'm at up X equal to so the load
can't store fast paired I know where is
this global load constant load fast I'm
not gonna get stuck here we're short on
time but it's the use of x by load fast
here there we go
so load fast of the X I think is
happening right here and then we call
the function which is the print trying
to use it but what's the load fast that
fails right so sorry I can't and that's
interesting the the fact that's called
load fast is related to fast locals
which you may have heard of which is
something that is on optimization in
Python anyway that's deeper than some of
you wanted to go maybe and here's the
exact from the frequently asked
questions in Python the exact
explanation of how test of why an
unbound local happens so you can go read
that later if you want to compile
explore some stuff on your own there a
few other things you can look at try the
difference and see how that shows up uh
how about global what does global do
well let's define it
all right so X is still was it one yeah
it was one and so what global does is it
tells python okay I don't want you to
create a local in this case I want you
to use the one that's global instead and
so in test global when we call that it's
gonna first print the one assign it to
four then print the four of course and
then X is going to be four when we're
done
don't use global if you can help it
sometimes you need it occasionally but
if we look at test global
it's it's similar I mean a self dot is
accessing an instance of a class we'll
look at classes later Global is saying
there's a name out there somewhere that
I want to use directly and I want to be
able to overwrite it not just read it in
a class structure I'm sorry
good not a good idea probably there's
usually a better way to do it there's
almost always a better way than using a
global when used but but almost again
emphasis on the almost right these are
rules of thumb so you can see that there
no there is no local X there is the
global prevented it from being created
Python 3 added a non-local keyword which
you see right here all right so I'm not
gonna go through this too slowly but you
can see X is 5 non-local X is gonna
refer to the 5 but not refer to the
global right so global it's like give me
my local one or go for the global
non-local means well just go up as far
as you need actually I don't know if
it's far but it's far I assume it says
go up as far as you need to to find it
as opposed to go up one level I actually
don't know if that's true but I expect
it is so we define this function and
it'll show us the various values let's
just make sure X is one ahead of time
yep and then we got tests on local X is
five five and then it becomes six but
the global X is still gonna be one okay
okay by the way I forgot to mention you
notice I'm going from section I camera
what number but we're at five point four
already I left these numbers the same as
the Epiphanes tutorial of the video in
case you want to reference it and/or do
that one or or look at the similar
numbering scheme from the PyCon video I
did back in April so these are skeptics
there are some of the sections I've cut
to give us done in 90 minutes
so can function argument can functions
modify what's passed to them all right
is Python by reference by by value
what's going on well
if met with our either renewed or deeper
understanding of how names work in
Python hopefully this will be really
clear to you all right so let's try this
function so test one a I pass it s and
it's going to try to do a plus equal
operation on it all right and so if I
say s equals s 1 equals 1 that's good if
I call test one and pass it s 1 what
will s1 be inside well we'll see the one
and then we'll see that one - and what
will s1 be afterwards it will be one it
won't be one - all right so this
function does some operations this
function does almost the same operation
instead of a plus equal I'm using an S
equal s plus two which by the way is not
only syntactic sugar there's actually
depending the object may implement plus
equal as a different operation than the
plus so it's not just syntactic sugar
and that's important in a few cases but
the point is if we see it this way let's
make that one change and let's make the
other change let's just pass in the
string 1 strings are immutable you can't
change the value of a string you can
just create new ones right well if we do
that then looking at this code it should
be more obvious to you that when we're
done the ones still gonna be 1 right and
I can't even really tell you that it
just it is I mean we could we get
printed again but point is that that
might be a little clearer to see that
these are really functionally very very
similar um and then this is sort of the
description of what's going on right so
in here in both cases in both functions
1a and 1b can again both on the screen
yes
in both cases what's happening is a the
string s which is oh and East Bay Oh any
is being concatenated with the string t
wo creating a new string and then
there's a namespace operation going on
somewhere to remember that and that name
is my name J's operation is here this
or s equal right so plus a point equal
or both it's the sort of our nation face
operation depending on how they're
implemented okay so let's try this with
a list so same code pretty much except
I've added it's just changed instead of
s its M instead of two it's square
bracket for a single list a listed with
a single value which is the integer for
all right so let's create a list make
sure it hasn't changed all right
feel like a magician let's make sure
it's really what I said it was all right
and when we're done what value does m1
have or maybe better said what object is
m1 refer to and what does that object
have well what was passed to test to a
was a reference alright so when I say
here when I say m1 I'm asking Python to
look in the current namespace and give
me back a reference to an object when I
call test to a and say m1 here Python
looks up the m1 gets back the reference
passes that reference off to the
function in the function a new name is
created by this namespace operation in
the def which says oh I want a name here
called M which rehearse and could have
been S or m7 or whatever which refers to
whatever reference like in this function
that reference that was passed in we can
use the name m and then here we said
well take that object and what happens
here actually is the M M in this case
refers to that list it's a second name M
for the same one to another two names M
pointing at the same list one in the
global scope one of the local functions
go and then it calls the plus equal
operation on that list which basically
asks the list to extend itself or to add
something to it it's saying here list
here's a new list please change your
contents to be the new list right and
just to prove that I'm not lying to you
there's the lists have changed okay so
as long as you think about the names and
the references the objects then what the
function does is it changing the object
or not that's the question whether or
not they're mutable or immutable that's
often there's a strong correlation the
immutable things can't be changed by the
function call but it really has to do
with the names and the reference is
passed in I saw a couple questions that
would be in general better probably
always better than using global I know
the cases where you need global you
really need it and it's these edge cases
they're all kind of different but in
general that would be a good plan yep
and and many people would say and I
think I'm becoming more saying this more
often myself is if you are passing
something in well if you can there are
sometimes efficiencies to passing in an
object and having it come back changed
there are some reasoning and testing
reasons why it's better to pass in an
object and get back a new object that
shows the change and those are sometimes
in tension the efficiency performance
versus keeping something purely
functional okay all right so let's look
at classes this is kind of a fun section
let's talk about classes at first at the
high level and then I'll show you how
things work the class statement starts a
block of code I didn't say this about
the DEF statement but the same way I
skipped the functions section it starts
a block of code which creates a new
namespace all namespace changes in the
block of code you know similar language
to all namespace changes are local I've
created a new block echo a code block
it's a new namespace
all the changes in that block everything
that's under indented under the class
statement is gonna make changes to that
namespace and those are things like
assignment in function definitions and
then it takes the class name and puts it
into the namespace where the class
statement appears it also takes that
class name at 16 in the class object
just like function took it put it two
places right and then this part here to
talk about the method object when you
access an attribute method name on a
class instance an instance of the class
if that name refers to a method in the
class what gets returned when you access
that same name on the instance is
something called a bound method
namespace operation yep yep ask me Morse
it later well we can keep that okay so
let's look at a simple little class
class number
I'm not inheriting for object as I'm
running Python 3 Oni - it's got so what
are the namespace operations that happen
well there's this one which is an
implicit setting of the attribute under
doc there's this one which is an
explicit setting of the attribute under
version there's this one which is a
function definition so the dunder init
name is going to show up in the number
classes namespace as well as showing up
in the code object the function object
this gets created by compiling this
thing and then there's the add all right
so I'll execute that and let's look at
what these do so what is the number
class it's got an init method which is
gonna take two arguments the object that
was already created as part of the call
to the call to the class all right so
the dunder init method in Python does
not create the object it's created
before that it's the dunder new method
which many of you have never heard of
and most of us never use that actually
creates the object the Dendera net just
initializes it and then we want to pass
it a second argument which is a mouse
this looks just like a function and in
fact it is a function trust me you'll
see and then it takes whatever we passed
as the second argument and adds an
attribute to the object which the
instance to just save it will save with
the same name self thought about right
and then self dot add well it's similar
we did we do a little instrumented here
so we could see what's happening and
then it just takes whatever we whatever
the instance is looks up it's a mount
attribute and adds whatever was passed
in and returns it quite simple let's uh
let's see some fun stuff so there's the
number so number is now a new name in
our namespace and I can access that
namespace looking at its version and
it's dunder doc and I can call help on
it and it gives me that dunder doc as
well as some other stuff that it
constructs
I can look at its dunder init access its
dunder init method and it gives me back
a function all right so I'm mixing
method and function here quite a bit in
my names in the names I'm using and
there's the add function of the number
class or add method of the file which is
a function or a method let's look at
screwed a little function here and show
you that here are the attributes that
don't start with double underscore of
the number class right so that's the way
you create an instance of a class you
call call it gets a callable so you can
put the parentheses before after it the
round brackets and put in in this case
I'm passing I'm not gonna do this little
racially right you know that the two
instance guy object got created it
creates the instance dunder Nick got
called okay so I'm gonna call this thing
and now I can look at number dot amount
because the thunderin it saved it for me
in the self self was a reference to the
object itself alright number two it's
not very pretty number 2 dot in it
member number dot in it dunder init was
a function number 2 dot dunder init is a
bound method all right so there's proof
that what I said before is true that
when we look up an attribute of an
instance and it goes up and looks in the
superclass to find it as a function it
does something special and returns you a
bound method ok let me digress for a
moment you don't need to understand this
to use classes effectively but it's part
of my broader theme of understanding
what's going on behind the scenes or
under the covers in Python under the
hood so you can understand I think that
level of understanding will help you
help you move along in language but
don't feel bad if you're not following
all of this number 2 dot ad same thing
bound method alright so if we look at
what's in number two we see add an
amount and we can actually see the only
difference is that amount is an
attribute on the instance it's no
an attribute on in the class right
because it was inside the self that it
added as an attribute of the instance
where does it add it and it's dunder
dict does number the class have a tender
dick
yes but it does not have ad in it okay
so a number the class has its own dunder
dick that it's not going to worry about
it does interesting things with it that
we don't care about
it's the dunder dicta on the instance
that holds the amount and add oh wait
yeah so yeah what I think the other
thing I want to point out here is that
so where's add it's not in number two's
tender dick but it gets it from numbers
okay and it's that referencing up like I
said that clear enough already
okay so what's uh there's the bound
method and we can call it so finally so
we call it and it tells us that it
called it and it returns a five right it
took the self-taught amount added which
was to added the three got the five
return the five let me show you some
unusual stuff here so number dot add is
uh we can see it's that function so this
I'm just showing you the reference I'm
not going to evaluate no need I'm just
showing you what the method definition
was up in the number class so if I call
number dot add with the number two I
should get back what I don't know what
number what's it gonna do it's gonna
call the function there's a function add
in the class and what error will I get
what's it like I think I heard someone
say self is undefined which is not it
won't even get that far it's gonna say
sorry you didn't even pass me the right
number of arguments right okay
so let's pass it the right number of
arguments how will this fail selves can
be defined amounts can be defined self
dot amount is not going to be defined
because two does not have an amount
attribute which is the value two right
so here we go
self-thought amount attribute err int
object has no attribute amount can I do
this can I call the function in the
number class passing it an instance of
the number class and another int and the
answer is yes and the answer is not yes
because it looks it doesn't look and say
his number to an instance of number
that's not why this worked the only
reason it worked is because the add
function looked for a first parameter
which and tried to use its amounts
attribute and it tried to add that to
the second parameter right duck typing
this is Python works not it's not doing
the only magic there's there's no magic
here right it just worked because we
passed the right number of parameters
and the parameters could do what we
asked them to do in the case of self
return an amount get an amount attribute
awfully what's that
the number two was passed as the first
parameter to the add function in the
number plus the number two is an
instance of the number class and in the
function add
it was named self okay so of course the
right way to do that is this alright so
don't do it I did okay now let's do some
more interesting thing remember the
dunder init function that we declared in
the class or we added to class if we
look at the number dot in it yeah we can
do help on it just to see what it looks
like a little bit take self an amount
well let's create a function this one I
mean evaluate let's create a function
called set double amount takes two
parameters number and amount and it
looks a lot like the dunder init except
instead of number I instead of self I'm
using number but self is just a
convention anyway and instead of equal
amount I'm saying 2 times amount now I'm
gonna do this cool that works
so now numbers dunder init attribute is
a function just like it was a function
before it's a different function this
time it even has a different name you
notice the names are different here
because I did it be an assignment
instead of via definition in the class
alright but we don't care that doesn't
matter what the name of the function is
when you call it you just have to get to
the object somehow and if we do it help
on it okay fine
alright so if I do that
did it work it did okay that's
monkey-patching
they've heard of Bank monkey-patching
this is it or dynamically doing
something to a class that you shouldn't
do dynamically you should do it through
a class typically or metaclass or
something more controlled oh I did have
one student two years ago come back to
me and say you know we actually found a
need for monkey-patching in production
and the kind of work stuff they were
doing I believed it anyway for some
definition of the word need so number
four can I add 5 to it and well sure and
if I look at number fours in its
function or method well again we call
the methods when they're defined in the
class in terms of the actual objects in
the class when you access them in the
class they're just a function as far as
python is concerned when you access them
from the instance you get something back
which is a bound method so method is the
right term
even at the class level I've been
calling them functions at the class
level to show the distinction right and
number two is init method of course that
was remember we changed number four
number four was added created after the
number class was monkey patched so
number two's init method or init
attribute it should be the old one well
no of course not because it doesn't
store it with the incidence that's
stored up in the class right so number
two that was created before I monkey
patch number the cat the capital n
number class its dunder init method
sorry dunder init attribute now also
refers to the set double amount method
that I've monkey patched in okay okay
let's add multiply foo this is a really
interesting class it's got multiply now
all right so let's add it it's there and
we call it and I get an error all right
so I added it multiplied by missing one
required positional argument value so it
only got passed one argument before it
got passed two arguments what's the
difference what's going on well here's a
hint right it says it's a function it
doesn't say it's a bound method all
right so can I call it like it's really
a function sort of the way I did number
dot add earlier capital n number add
yeah I can so
so it's it's a function it's not about
method and the answer is where's the
mistake is I added you'll see it if you
if we do this let's create a new
instance of the new number the new
monkey patch number and let's look at
its can't even find it right so number
ten we got this number class we got
number four and we've got number ten if
we look at number Ten's mole method it
can't even find it when it goes it can't
find on instance can't find in the class
why because I put it on the instance
before so I did a bad mistake with my
bad monkey patching right and we can see
their public there-there's number Ten's
got it's got both add and amount these
are the things you can get to but one of
them is coming from the but in this case
amount well right the ad is coming from
the class but not the x there's no
there's no mole in this list and there's
no mole in this list or as we look at
number four well there's the mole it's
only on the instance so what we need to
do is put it on the class right so now
number Ten's
mole it's gonna work and of course
number four is motion work too right why
not
why is number four is no I put it in the
right place well let's look at the dirt
public yeah it's there let's look at its
dunder dict uh okay so now I put it on
the instance instead of on the class I
fixed it by putting on the class I never
removed it from the instance so this
instance number ten gets it from the
class this instance got it in two places
in a sense it's got it on the instance
and on the class it gets the instance
first so it's returning a function not
about method right so a simple namespace
operation will fix that and now I can
see that the dict only has what it
should it still shows up as one of the
attributes you can get to from number
four angers a second and it's a bound
method when I access
when I look at the class it shows up as
a function object and I can call it good
segue I think we'll see if I think this
will help it become clear
it might not so how does this actually
work what's going on with with classes
in Python okay so here's the number
class
it's got here's number four which is
this object the instance of the class
number here's the add function and
here's the add method right and again
when I say when I say the got ID I'm
feeling a little bit bad about calling
us a function number dot add is a method
but when you access it directly on the
class it returns a function so this is
part of the magic I'm trying to get you
understand it what pythons doing behind
the scenes by the way about methods by
themselves are nice right if I want to
create a new function which adds
whatever you pass to it it adds four to
it I can just go like this
I just say let me save number fours add
attribute which returns me a bound
method save it with another name and it
looks a lot like a function doesn't it I
can say add two four six and I'll get
back to him and that will live beyond
any other stuff getting deleted because
there's a reference to it okay so number
four those are the
yep yep that's what's coming so if we
look at number fours at number four dot
adds so I'm gonna look at this bound
method that when I access the add
attribute on the instance I get back an
object which is a bound method that
bound method has a bunch of stuff in it
including some public things well not
many actually look at that so if I look
at the difference there those the ones
that are different between what the
class function has as attributes and the
bound method that gets returned that
wraps the function returns right the
attributes of that so the difference is
the bound method has everything that the
function has plus it has it done your
function and um yourself what's like it
done yourself it's the instance so
number fours adds done yourself is the
same object that number four refers to
okay there's proof that used is to say
are they the same yep those two names
refer to the same thing and number fours
adds attribute which returns a bound
methods func attribute is the function
from the class right and it's also the
same as that right so that so these
bound methods are all sharing these
bound method object gets to return
they're all using a reference to the
function to do their work so when I say
number four dot add five it's pretty
much like I said this number four dot
add under func it calls this function
passing it this self and passing it to
five so that's actually how Python does
method lookup it calls pretty easy a you
could have written that I mean the like
you think about Python what's nice is
one of the really nice things about
Python lots of things one is its
consistent in lots of places and the
other is it just uses it exposes the
stuff so we can play with it and it just
implements it by the stuff it exposes
oh seven minutes so the question that I
didn't answer if it's still a question
ask me afterwards please so just give me
another 10 seconds to decide I'll fly
seven minutes I will just fly through
the next three sections so this one you
can create a class by creating functions
and then calling the type built-in
function and passing it a certain set of
things you pass it the name and here's
how you can see how it actually happens
in both places you pass it the list of
super classes base classes sorry and
then you pass it a dictionary which is
the attributes to create that's actually
how it metaclasses work in python if you
ever wondered what a meta class is a
meta class is a class with some notation
different in Python 2 & 3 which says
don't use the type function use this
other function that I'm providing for
you and that other function of course is
well not of course but it's going to do
some fancy stuff and then call the type
function to finish the work or possibly
call the type function and then finish
some work so sort of lets you stick some
stuff into the that's exactly how Matic
classes work so no if I do this it all
just works although you might want to be
careful you notice here I use the word
number here and I used the word number
here the same string that's a good idea
to keep those the same yeah and there's
the normal way you created okay
I'm gonna skip the exercise one but this
is a really cool exercise if you've ever
wondered if you if you're still confused
by decorators and how they work this
example and the examples that I didn't
include that you can get from the off
the O'Reilly Sites fuller version of
this or the download will help you think
about decorators
just about a namespace operation the
namespace operation which is a decorator
and I think that for a lot of people can
sort of go oh it's simple and then you
can start thinking about instead of
trying to think about the namespace
operation and what decorators are good
for you can think about them separately
anyway I'm gonna skip this part it's
kind of interesting I'm going to show
you a couple little examples for
generator functions let me just show you
these two examples so why use generator
functions they're more efficient they
don't chew up a lot of RAM they're also
simpler right here is a generator
function just use a yield instead of a
return and it turns it into an object
that you can play with when you go
around this code later if you decide to
all right
there's version 1 version 2 anyone I
want to argue that version 2 is simpler
i gets version ones less lines of code
we don't have to worry about saving the
result we just let the yield do it for
us and use them the same way right they
work the same in terms of a for loop and
then here's some more example another
example of one so last three sections I
want to maybe cover in four minutes is
just a couple examples with the
first-class objects so I want to create
a function that is a little mini
calculator that works with three
characters the reason I'm showing you
this example is many of you if you are
as you're learning Python one of the
things you need to work against is the
narrowing of your imagination that you
learned that you were taught by all the
other languages you all the other
languages you've used in the past all
right
in Python you can do things you can't do
in other languages and I've got two or
three examples here that try to help you
say oh let me think of other ways of
doing this and that's one of the things
that's I think can take a long time in
Python is to think beyond what you're
used to thinking right if you used to
using the hammer and then someone gives
you a pair of pliers what I do with
these pair of pliers you keep solving it
the old way think of new ways so let me
just run through this quick example and
I think that will end with that so 7
plus 3 I want to it early develop a
function that lets me pass that string
to a calc
function and computes the answer so
here's one way I'll just do the
expression equals and then I've got in a
name I'll do this tuple unpacking right
I'll convert the strings to intz I'll
move them around all right so now I've
got the plus in the seven-to-three and
then I could just do a little if if + -
- / / fill this works but you notice
there's a lot of duplication in here the
only thing different is the + in quotes
and the + not in single quotes etc but
we can see that this works and if we
call perform operation it works so let's
instead import operator which is a
module in the standard library that
exposes all the built-in operators as
names once you have it as a name you can
call it like that I can just say add 7
comma 3 the same thing that runs the
same code that if you put 7 plus 3 runs
now I can create a dictionary and here
again most you Joe you can do that
Python but this is this is something you
can't do in a lot of languages is I can
have a dictionary that map's from a
single character and maps to an object
well of course it's an object everything
can Python is an object this is an
object which is a function so you can
call it right so I create that mapping
and now I can actually access the
function and I can call the function
right so I can say give me the function
that's stored in the dictionary under
the key + call it passing at 7 + 3 and I
get back to 10 nice so now I can change
my perform operations you just do that
instead of if then if you know the three
if statements all right and I wrap it
all up in my calc function that pulls
together those pieces of code and Kelvin
plus 3 works and calc 9-5 works and
calculate / 3 works and calc three times
four doesn't work and if I want to fix
this I don't need to go add an if
statement I just changed the data
structure that is encoding what I want
to do right so simple example
I have another example here that I'm
gonna skip and an example further on
with just more general treatment of how
various ways you can bind data with
functions which is what the bound method
does but there's a lot some other ways
to do as well so thanks for coming I
encourage you to go download the fuller
sight thing and play with you yourself
or watch the video or look at the PyCon
video feel free to come bug me
afterwards with questions I hope it was
helpful oh there is a there's that you
can go to the PyCon website PyCon v
video and look for it you can go buy it
from over O'Reilly that's a newer
version this one the PyCon one's
slightly older okay